The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw@mit.edu.
AMIT GANDHI: So
today, we're going
to be doing a little hands-on
wind turbine building activity.
So by the end--
if you guys remember
from the first class,
lab session, where
we cut and sawed
things apart using
different hand tools,
well, the end
product is supposed
to be something that
looks like this.
It's pretty simple.
The way it works is--
the way it works is you
have this wooden dowel,
and you're mounting
a wind turbine on it.
When you blow on this in
this direction, it spins.
It has magnets
attached to the bottom.
And then you're making coils
with electromagnetic wire.
And so as the magnets
spin by the coils,
you're inducing a current
and generating electricity.
STUDENT: Hey, how are you doing?
STUDENT: Not bad.
What are we doing here?
STUDENT: We are just starting
to assemble this together,
so it's pretty vague.
STUDENT: Oh, this is--
so do we just have to cut the
bottles in half right now?
STUDENT: I think so.
STUDENT: Oh, I don't know.
Does this not stay on here?
STUDENT: No, it says blue here.
But this is--
I don't know how--
I don't think I can
screw this in like that.
Stupid thing.
STUDENT: It does
smell like soap.
It actually smells really good.
Why scent is that?
STUDENT: When it's turning,
it's going to smell.
STUDENT: It's going to
be like an air freshener.
STUDENT: It didn't have
this box originally.
AMIT GANDHI: So if you guys
feel like changing the design
at all, because you think
something makes more sense,
or you want to make any
improvements to the design,
you should feel free to.
Don't feel like have to
follow the directions
like every step of the way.
STUDENT: OK.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
STUDENT: I got it.
STUDENT: Nice.
STUDENT: Wow, that is excellent.
STUDENT: We have to-- do we
have to do a piece between them?
STUDENT: We need two of these.
STUDENT: Yeah, but do we need
something in between these two?
STUDENT: I don't think so.
STUDENT: I think the idea was--
STUDENT: 61, 62, 63, 64.
STUDENT: The coils are
going to end up being--
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
STUDENT: 68, 69, 70,
71, 72, 73, 74, 75.
AMIT GANDHI: Wait, are you
doing all four coils first?
You should do all
four coils at once.
But make sure you leave space,
like wire between the coils
so you do separate.
STUDENT: So just
start over here now?
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah, but I mean,
drop more wire between the two.
STUDENT: Oh, so we
can lay them out?
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah.
Because you want to
lay them like that.
And so you just need enough
wire to go from here, to here,
to here, to here.
STUDENT: Oh, OK.
So I can take this off?
AMIT GANDHI: Well, you
could just pull on--
STUDENT: Move it over here?
AMIT GANDHI: Or you could
just leave this much wire,
then start your
next coil like that.
STUDENT: OK, should I--
we probably need to wrap a
few of these just a couple
more times.
STUDENT: Mhm.
STUDENT: I'd like
to cut this off.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
STUDENT: OK, ready?
STUDENT: Oh, we need the glue.
Got it.
STUDENT: Can I steal a glove?
STUDENT: Oh, yeah, but did
they break the wire off there?
STUDENT: This is definitely
not designed for manufacturing.
STUDENT: No.
STUDENT: Oh, we glued it too
tall, guys, or too low down.
STUDENT: What happened?
STUDENT: It must
have slid a little.
It's now hitting the thing.
STUDENT: Oh, good.
Nice.
STUDENT: Ah, we're so clever.
STUDENT: Nice.
STUDENT: I read the post, paper.
STUDENT: Whoa,
somebody in our group
actually read the [INAUDIBLE].
Can you hand me the glue?
STUDENT: So this should be--
[WHIRRING]
STUDENT: You want AC, right?
[BEEP]
STUDENT: I'm measuring current.
STUDENT: Oh, you're
measuring current?
STUDENT: Yeah.
STUDENT: It doesn't seem
to be doing anything.
AMIT GANDHI: You are measuring
connectivity across the wire.
STUDENT: We measured that, yeah.
There's 17 ohms across
it, which probably
makes sense for the amount
of tiny wire we have.
STUDENT: No, we're
measuring amperes
STUDENT: What?
[CLATTERING]
STUDENT: There you go.
That was our mistake.
Never mind.
[INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT: It's really hot.
The [INAUDIBLE] it's the
core variant of the current.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
STUDENT: I have
something backwards.
I have something backwards.
I'm going to go get
some more light.
STUDENT: Well, it's
pretty far now, actually.
STUDENT: Really?
So we can put this together?
STUDENT: So we should
try to straighten this,
you know what I mean?
STUDENT: Yeah.
STUDENT: Can we have
the electric tube back?
STUDENT: This close
to you is [INAUDIBLE]..
I don't care if
it's close to me.
STUDENT: But it's just tilted.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So if you see that one moving.
So then if we just stick that--
STUDENT: Every time you
pull, you move the coil.
STUDENT: We're moving the coils?
STUDENT: Yeah.
You want to re-tape all of them?
STUDENT: --mine and see
if it's good enough.
STUDENT: I'm going
to go pull out mine.
[INAUDIBLE] over here.
I know there's one over there.
STUDENT: Cool.
STUDENT: Wow, that
is much better.
STUDENT: Yeah.
That one, [INAUDIBLE] make
it a little bit closer.
I don't know if this is going
to be a fine enough rating.
But we're getting 0.4.
0.4, 0.5, 0.6.
STUDENT: Oh, man.
STUDENT: Awesome.
STUDENT: It's doing 0.4
more than anything else.
It went to 0.8 for a second.